et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
nicolas dupont aignan bonjour bonjour
madame et aux coûts et d'être avec nous
député de l'essonne et président de
debout la france on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par fabrice
veysseyre redon bonjour fabrice bonjour
aurillac du groupe ebra sur les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france
on commence bien sûr par jean castex qui
est venu hier devant le parlement
nicolas dupont aignan présenter les
mesures sanitaires on va parler du fond
des mesures dans quelques instants mais
d'abord sur le vote contrairement à la
grande majorité des oppositions vous
avez pris part au vote il erre vous avez
voté contre
est ce que ça veut dire que vous
désapprouvez le boycott organisé par les
oppositions
non je le comprends parce que le
parlement est un paillasson
depuis depuis mars puis à ne plus d'un
an on est en état d'urgence sanitaire
est en fait on ne vote que rien pour
autant j'estime est ce mon choix que ne
pas participer au vote c'est ne pas dire
sa position c'est en un côté un peu
politicien et je peux comprendre
j'aurais pu le faire mais j'ai préféré
moins voté pour une fois on avait le
vote l'utiliser et dire clairement je
vote contre
parce que je crois que dans la vie
politique il faut dire les choses comme
elles sont voilà mais je ne juge pas du
tout mes collègues qui n'ont pas pris
part au vote je les comprends aussi
c'est une autre façon de manifester lors
d un drop a three a jusqu'à dire comme
la majorité présidentielle que ceux qui
n'ont pas voté ont fait preuve de
lâcheté de manque de moi j'attends et
leurs positions non vous savez à force
de tirer sur la corde elle casse
voilà le gouvernement en fait décide
quand on doit voter
donc je comprends très bien ou pas
polémiquer avec mes collègues qui ont
bien eu raison de dire stop
moi je lui dis à ma façon d'une voilà
c'est tout et la portance et le fond
faux sur le avant de parler du fond des
mesures avec fabrice pour finir sur le
parlement vous dit quand même que
l'exécutif considère le parlement comme
un paillasson mais bien évidemment
puisque attendez j'ai pas si vous
réalisez que nous le sommes l'une de
seules démocraties où depuis plus d'un
an le parlement et court-circuité et ne
dit a donné les pleins pouvoirs en
matière sanitaire
mais c'est très large parce que les
ordonnances sont très larges en matière
sanitaire à l'exécutif que ça va durer
jusqu'au 1er juin et que ça peut durer
jusqu'au 31 décembre cela veut dire que
presque pendant deux ans le parlement
aura été suspendu on n'a jamais vu ça
donc je veux dire que la situation est
très grave démocratiquement très grave
et j'ai beaucoup protesté à l'époque au
moment du vote des pleins pouvoirs
j'appelle ça des pleins pouvoirs de
triste mémoire
c'est terrible ce qui se passe
d'ailleurs j'avais pleins pouvoirs c'est
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
bah oui mais l'état d'urgence sanitaire
ça veut dire que les représentants du
peuple non plus leur mot à dire sur des
privations de liberté de circulation
c'est terrible ce qui se passe donc
voilà le recon très grave et d'ailleurs
je n'ai jamais compris l'intérêt jamais
l'intérêt jamais compris l'intérêt du
président de la république parce que ça
veut dire qu'en fait il des sites où ils
l'avouent alors qu'il a une majorité que
quand même assez docile et qu'il aurait
pu au moins faire voter par sa majorité
les textes non c'est à dire que là il ya
vraiment un dysfonctionnement très
profond des institutions c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous avez voté contre il
ya une autre raison d'ordre sanitaire
voilà non j'ai voté contre parce que moi
je réponds la question j'ai mon analyse
sur les institutions elles sont bafouées
et quand on me demande quand il ya un
vote je l'utilisent parce que je pense
que ces mesures sanitaires sont
contre-productives et que surtout le
gouvernement ne prend pas les bonnes
mesures qui permettraient demain
d'éviter le quatrième confinement vous
prendriez quoique mesure alors j'ai
depuis le début depuis si vous reprenez
toutes mes interventions notamment mes
vidéos sur facebook depuis le 26 janvier
je demande contrôle des frontières c'est
vers ça n'a jamais été fait et ça a été
fait au dernier moment et encore ce
n'est pas fait correctement depuis que
cela a été décidé et que tu n'es pas
fait correctement je suis allé battre
elle c'est à dire que c'est on rentre
comme dans un moulin en france que les
contrôles ne sont pas sérieux est ce que
vient de faire l'italie c'est à dire ce
qu'elle du bon sens
un double test permettrait et aurait
permis si ça avait été fait l'été
dernier
l'entrée les variants donc il faut
absolument le contrôle des frontières
deuxième point que je demande depuis un
an c'est l'augmentation des lits de
réanimation pérenne pas délit de secours
qui sont pris sur d'autres lits délit
pérenne avec la réouverture du val de
grâce qui possible c'est techniquement
possible mais oui bien sûr et je vais
vous dire comment d'ailleurs si on avait
commencé il ya un an parce que je vais
pas vous dire qu'on double nombre de
lits de réanimation en deux mois il faut
plusieurs années mais il faut commencer
le plus tôt possible et on pouvait
rouvrir le val de grâce parce qu'on a la
chance d'avoir un hôpital tout près
d'ici je vous invite à aller loire en
parfait état qui peut être trouvée en
deux mois ce qui aurait permis de
d'accueillir les malades qu'ovide de
soulager les autres services ensuite de
trier en fonction des états de gravité
et on peut le faire en terme de
personnel parce que bien sûr j'entends
toujours le même argument du
gouvernement c c'est pas des lycées du
personnel mais oui mais j'aurais
augmenter le concours d interne puisque
le gouvernement à limiter à 74 pour des
internes en réanimation
on est toujours au même chiffre que
l'année d'avant j'aurais utilisé
beaucoup plus la réserve sanitaire
j'aurais mis une prime très forte pour
les infirmières qui reviennent qui vient
de partir en retraite en réanimation
notamment et qui moyennant une très
forte prime complémentaire de leur
retraite serait bien revenue quelques
mois bref ce que je reproche les lie
ensuite les soins diffusion des bonnes
pratiques la protection cibler la
protection cibler les masques ffp2 qu'on
aurait dû envoyer aux personnes les plus
fragiles comme l'a fait madame merkel à
l'aser master jai coquelin bien sûr
parce que vous pouvez avoir un
confinement très dur et puis vous pouvez
voir une personne très fragile qui va
dans un supermarché avec un masque en
tissu à la trappe ralago vide donc c'est
complètement ridicule
donc pourquoi madame merkel a envoyé à
27 millions d'allemands à l'autre 15
masques ffp2 qui sont coûteux c'est pour
les protéger dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles
et puis le dernier point quelle évidence
mais qui est toujours pas fait c'est une
stratégie de tester tracé isolé sérieuse
les eaux usées le la
et un flat les eaux usées c'est fait
mais non c'est pas fait pardonnez-moi ya
des contrôles sur les errances dans
quelques endroits 13 très exceptionnel
c'est pas du tout systématisée il ya
d'autres mesures technologiques
l'oxymètre l'oxymètre mais tous les
français devraient en avoir un les
personnes âgées du moins parce que ça
devance le test le purificateur d'air la
mairie du 9e j'ai eu la maire du 9e au
téléphone cette semaine la maire du 9e
amis des purificateurs d'air dans toutes
ses classes
pourquoi on attend le spray nasal qui
est en vente en israël l'autotest qui
est en vente libre depuis le début mars
en allemagne
donc on en fait tout un pays on est en
train de tuer un pays parce qu'on ne
naît pas capables de prendre des mesures
ciblées
si on tient à vous entendre on a
l'impression que c'est facile heures
pourquoi si c'est si facile le
gouvernement ne le fait pas parce qu'on
comprend pas bien mais moi non plus mais
je peux vous dire on a l'impression que
celle ci l'est c'est facile d'ouvrir des
mais pourquoi s'est fait ailleurs en
place pourquoi l'italie a ouvert un
nombre de lits incalculables a retrouvé
au moins trente mille personnel soignant
si c'est pas cinquante mille vous
vérifierez le chef
le chiffre mais pourquoi pourquoi ce
pays est paralysé pourquoi notre pays
est paralysé pourquoi l'institut pasteur
de lille
je donne un exemple très précis c'est
pas moi c'est sérieux l'institut pasteur
de lille en plus soutenus a été obligé
d'aller chercher une subvention de lvmh
lvmh n'est pas complotistes que je sache
puisque dès qu on dit quelque chose on
nous accuse de complotisme l'institut
pasteur de lille à trouver une molécule
ancien pas cher qui permettrait
j'emploie le conditionnel vraiment
d'avoir des résultats exceptionnels
monsieur salomon a freiné les études 9
février dernier
les études sont freinés vous trouvez ça
normal dans un pays adultes vous trouvez
normal que l'ivermectine soit freinée ta
scandale mais ça sera un scandale d'état
parce que la république tchèque vient de
l'autoriser la slovaquie quantité de
pays
je ne dis pas que ces médicaments
miracles je n'ai jamais dis ça je dis
simplement que dans notre pays
soit vous avez vous êtes chez vous avec
du doliprane la médecine de ville et
court-circuité soit vous allez à
l'hôpital
les biens entre les deux
- nicolas dupont-aignan l'ivermectine
c'est pas con france alors cette halle
agence du médicament france ne
l'autorisent pas et dit qu'il faut des
études complémentaires mais nous elles
non plus ne tarissent pas l' agence
européenne et l'agencé européenne
on la connaît c'est elle qui évolue
n'est pas qu'un problème français en
classe il a voulu c'est un problème
européen
c'est elle qui a voulu nous à casino
l'autorisation peut finir c'est elle qui
a voulu nous caser leur haine des civils
qu'elle a fait acheter à la commission
de bruxelles temps à acheter pour des
centaines de millions sous la pression
de laboratoires
mais il ya eu 24 études dont 16 ou 12 en
double aveugle sur l'ivermectine qui est
généralisé dans beaucoup de pays
je ne dis pas soyons précis moi je suis
pas médecin je constate simplement que
beaucoup de médecins utilisent en france
sous le prétexte de la gale et que ça
diminue la charge virale devenir
considérable constaté aussi que l'
agence française ne le trahisse pas que
la jambe a oui ou connaît le lobby vous
voudriez que c'est bien je voudrais
c'est s'autoriser pour les français ben
oui parce que il ya des résultats
extraordinaires et je trouve quand même
curieux
je m'étonne que et je demanderai à une
commission d enquête parlementaire là
dessus parce que je suis j'ai pressé des
jambes sur ces sujets des traitements
précoces parce que je voudrais
comprendre comment les anticorps
monoclonaux qui coûte 2000 euros la dose
qui ne sont qu'en face d'eux qu'ils ont
aucune
une étude ou deux ont été autorisés par
l' agence et que des médicaments des
anciennes molécules qui ont fait leurs
preuves dans beaucoup de pays c'est pas
dupont aignan qui dit c'est plein de
pays sont autorisés et nous ça l'est pas
donc il ya quand même un vrai scandale à
la demande des études complément prix
alors quand c'est un grand laboratoire
pharmaceutique et que ça coûte plus de
2000 euros la dose y a pas besoin
d'études alors que quand c'est une
molécule qui a été vendue à 4 milliards
par un prix nobel de la paix prix nobel
de médecine japonais qui est utilisé
dans temps plein deux pays c'est niet
pourquoi les purificateurs d'air ne sont
toujours pas autorisés pourquoi le spray
nasal n'est pas autorisée alors je ne
dis pas qu'il ya grand complot et on va
avancer
j'insiste et j'insiste pourquoi ce
retard sur vous sur les vaccins contre
la toux qu'on va voir les malades en ald
et à vous parler de retard les chiffres
au bout d'un an de pandémie les chiffres
mondiaux vient d'être diffusée non et
qui ont une réalité en tout cas qui sont
ils fiables
vous parlez des allemands tout à l'heure
on peut parler des anglais est ce que
finalement au bout d'un an la france est
si mauvaise que ça quand vous regardez
les chiffres très mauvaise regardez les
chiffres justement nous sommes dans les
pires résultats
et regardez le nombre de pays puis elle
je parle pas au niveau d'une part mort
et par habitant mort par habitant vous
savez qu'on est au niveau du brésil
parce qu'on siffle on met les chiffres
en valeur absolue mais par habitant donc
regarder les regarder les chiffres par
habitant essayer de comprendre ce que
moi j'ai essayé dès le début pourquoi
des pays comme le maroc le maroc qu'à
soigner entre parenthèses à l'hydroxyde
rockin bon le sénégal qui est beaucoup
plus jeune donc il faut pas bien
évidemment un attention il ya la tranche
d'âge donc mais quand même
pourquoi le maroc à mieux vacciner que
la france comme extraordinaire pourquoi
des pays comme la pologne
pourquoi des pays d'europe de l'est
pourquoi je parle pas de la russie
on peut voir les chiffres je parle de
pays qui ne sont pas les pays asiatiques
et asiatiques ont une vraie stratégie
intelligente qu'on n'a pas mis en place
mais au-delà de ça et donc je suis plus
sur la stratégie zéro coville j étais au
début mais maintenant c'est trop tard
donc pourquoi des pays sont réactifs à
ce que ces salles interrogation pourquoi
des pays sont réactifs et pourquoi notre
pays est paralysé par une bureaucratie
qui semblent tétanisés et qui quand il
ya une innovation mais pas les quatre
fois plus de temps à la mettre en oeuvre
c'est quand même une interrogation enfin
pour moi un mot à mot juste puisque vous
parlez des tests il ya quelques jours
vous avez dit que vous demander
l'interdiction de l'école pour les
enfants dont les parents refusent le
test est ce que tu étais trop long vous
êtes allé projet était trop loin j'ai
franchement parfois il faut reconnaître
quand on va trop loin
mais j'étais trop loin pourquoi parce
que jean michel aphatie me poussée dans
mes retranchements et j'aurais dû me
méfier
très sincèrement pourquoi parce que je
pense qu'il faut laisser les écoles
ouvertes
parce que je voulais qu'on fasse tout
pour laisser les écoles ouvertes et
j'avais imaginé la solution dès 2000
groupe parce que je voulais éviter la
cantine et j'avais dit est-ce qu'on peut
pas avoir le système de test pulling qui
a aux états unis où en allemagne c'est à
dire que les enfants crash tous dans une
bassine et si dans la bassine
il ya un truc positif à ce moment là on
fait des tests à tout le monde et ça
marche très bien
purificateurs d'air purificateurs d'air
ventilation l'alcool dans son honneur
parce qu'en face on a pu décoller alors
c'est réglé jacques ans je voudrais
qu'on accélère sur les purificateurs
d'air je voudrais pourquoi pas faire des
groupes
j'aurais d'ailleurs pas fermer toutes
les écoles de france dans les zones de
bretagne en les zones il ya peu
d'épidémie l état a été réalisé pour les
et je le pense et je paie pas d
inégalités scolaires entre les enfants
tête mais enfin dans la vie tout ce qui
peut être préservée en matière scolaire
parce que je vois j'ai vu à ce que
j'appelle lobby en ferme east qui ne
vois absolument pas les conséquences
sociales dramatiques sur des enfants et
je pense entre nous que on pourrait
élargir le couvre-feu je vais vous
provoquer à 21h que tu as et les gens
dans les transports en passant de 19h à
21h oui bien sûr deuxièmement que on
pourrait ouvrir les commerces ça n'a
aucun sens sa fermeture
la règle des 10 km et comprennent ils
demi bien sûr la règle des 10 km n'a
aucun sens en revanche en revanche
soyons précis beaucoup plus de prudence
dans les comportements est beaucoup plus
de sévérité dans les zones où aucune
mesure barrière n'est respectée vous
avez des centaines de quartiers en
france il n'ya 0 mesures barrières je
vous emmène
je vous prends rer et je vous emmène
dans certains quartiers de ma région que
je connais bien il n'y a pas de masque
il ya des faits toute la nuit
voilà donc moi je veux bien qu'on
emmerde ça veut dire que le gouvernement
raison de faire plus de contrôles hier
non tarifée à pas les contrôler mon
endroit excusez moi non et de certaines
personnes non il fait les contrôles pour
emmerder les français sur désolé de
parler comme ça m'embêtait les français
parce qu'ils vont rentrer à 19h15 au
lieu de 19h
parce que ils vont faire ceci cela c'est
tellement facile de faire des contrôles
sur des honnêtes gens
mais en revanche je peux vous dire que
d'aller dans des quartiers difficiles
or rien n'est respecté il n'y a pas un
policier pas un gendarme parce qu'ils se
font caillasser et que l'état est
défaillant
donc moi j'aimerais qu'on soit plus
sévère là où les gestes barrière ne sont
pas respectés et qu'on soit beaucoup
plus intelligent là où la liberté
allié à la prudence est beaucoup plus
efficace
un mot sur le pass annie terre puisque
vous êtes un opposant pas sanitaire
selon les informations de france info ce
matin le gouvernement abandonnerait se
passer ni terrasse que vous êtes
satisfait mais bien sûr parce que ça n'a
aucun sens si on est vaccinés quel est
l'intérêt de la vaccination d'après le
gouvernement c'est d'être protégés donc
si vous êtes vacciné vous pouvez aller
au cinéma au restaurant vous ne craignez
rien même s'il ya quelqu'un qui est pas
vacciner puisque le principe même du
vaccin c'est pas d'empêcher la
transmission c'est d'empêcher les formes
graves
donc le pass sanitaire n'a aucun sens
aucun sens que vous êtes satisfait
depuis je l'espère venance dans la
vaccination non puisqu'on en a pas parlé
fabresse oui sur la vaccination pour
vous le rythme et le tempo le calendrier
qui a été donnée vous convient mais je
ne crois plus personne ne croit le
gouvernement
on va attendre on va attendre de voir
voilà je peux pas vous dire plus puisque
le gouvernement a dit tout et son
contraire je crois que monsieur vers en
était allé sur tf1 pour nous dire qu'il
aurait 70 millions de personnes
vaccinées au 1er juin ou à la fin de
l'été à la fin de l'été bon tout ça est
grotesque puisque le manuel de quoi
enfin il dit que non les adultes qui le
souhaitent il est ce que ça vous y
croyait mais je n'y crois en rien mais
j'espère qu'il tiendra ses promesses
mais comme ça fait quinze fois qu'on
nous dit tout le contraire de tout
j'attends mais vous savez le vrai
problème n'est pas là si je peux me
permettre d'aller là mais est-ce qu'on
va tirer les leçons en terme de
relocalisation des centres de production
de médicaments réellement vous pouvez
reconnaît ça fait dix ans que j'alerte
sur les délocalisations
j'avais vu il ya plus de dix ans un
directeur d usine pharmaceutique qui
m'avait alerté j'avais écrit dans le
désert le plus total le vrai enjeu c'est
la capacité de l'europe et de la france
a retrouvé des chaînes de valeur sur
tout le territoire et on en est encore
là
alors là tu as tout le monde est
d'accord en paroles mais pour passer à
l'acte par exemple l'entreprise luxfer
qui produisait des bouteilles d'oxygène
et que j'avais proposé qu'on rachète qui
était fermé et qui rentable le
gouvernement a refusé de le faire et
nous dépendons des bouteilles d'oxygène
fabriqué en angleterre pour toute
l'europe
donc moi je veux bien les discours mais
les masques ffp2 vous avez quand il y en
a importé de masques de chine 5
milliards d'euros cette année
2020 5 milliards d'euros et je vois que
le gouvernement ou l'état ne commandent
toujours des masques au vietnam wire
alors qu'il ya des usines françaises en
bretagne qui ont été relancés mais par
un dévouement et une force de d'énergie
des entrepreneurs inouïe mais je veux
dire que si on ne traduit pas dans les
actes maintenant les leçons de la crise
on va se retrouver dans le même état
dans un deux ans sur les régionales et
oui intimement liée à la crise sanitaire
à la question du calendrier des
régionales le conseil scientifique a
renvoyé la responsabilité au
gouvernement de conserver cette étape du
mois de juin ou de reporter un petit peu
plus tard dans l'année votée en juin ça
vous paraît raisonnable
oui au jour d'aujourd'hui enfin au jour
d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui quelle
horrible formule bien sûr fois arrêter
de changer les calendriers si vraiment
il y avait un pic épidémique énorme
le 13 juin est évident qu'on pourrait
reporter en septembre ça serait faire
injure annoncé pendant une semaine la le
pic épidémique mais en attendant au mois
de juin on en sera sorti
donc de grâce un peu de calme de sang
froid pour moi on ne touche pas on
touche pas faut arrêter de se dire qu'on
touche d'ailleurs dans tous les pays on
vote on va bien au supermarché avec un
masque enfin il faut arrêter la psychose
l'affolement général qui est malsain on
n'a pas parlé économie mais on est en
train de détruire un pays il ya des gens
dans la misère qu'ils mangent pas à leur
faim dans notre pays contrairement à ce
qu'on dit il ya des 3 millions d'
indépendants qu'on pas d'indemnités
donc moi je veux bien qu'on te casse
tout parce qu'on n'a pas été capable de
voir des lits des soins des masques mais
sur les régionales debout la france
autre partie sera dans
pas de partis pas partout nous serons
dans certaines régions l'ile-de-france
dans les hautes france en paca et dans
beaucoup d'autres régions mais pas
partout pour des raison simple c'est que
ça dépend des régions voilà en est mais
c'est quoi ça défend des forces qu'on a
en région ça dépend des alliances il
peut y avoir un certain dragon les
candidats on les a c'est pas le problème
des candidats c'est le problème que ce
soit utile et je vous cache pas aussi
soyons très précis que je suis candidat
à la présidentielle que le pays dans un
état déplorable et que pour moi ce qui
compte et pour notre mouvement s'appelle
debout la france est pas par hasard
c'est vraiment de proposer aux français
un choix de redressement national
différents de ceux qui sont présents oui
absolument
vous serez en mesure d'être candidat à
la présidentielle
bien évidemment les maires qui vous
avait parrainé avant votre ralliement à
au front national en 2010 est bon vous
redonnez dans signature alors d'abord il
ya un terme que je n'aime pas ce mot
ralliement j'ai fait ce que monsieur
bertrand a fait pour monsieur macron
monsieur fillon
je les fais pour madame le pen je n'ai
jamais eu un ralliement au front
national
et voyez comme les choses sont perverses
parfois elle a compris cette loi que
vous avez dans ce que je fais pour
monsieur ben content j'ai fait quand
monsieur bertrand
monsieur fillon annonce un quart d'heure
après le premier tour qu'ils vont
soutenir de toutes leurs forces
monsieur macron personnes motards
s'opposer à marine le pen
oui d'accord mais se soutenir monsieur
macron personne ne leur dit le
ralliement à en marche
j'ai soutenu et j'assume totalement
contre monsieur macro madame le pen pour
autant debout la france est toujours
restée partie attendez je finis un des
deux partis indépendants et je suis
candidat gaulliste parce que j'ai un
projet pour le pays
et d'ailleurs je vois qu'il ya 7 % des
français ce qui est quand même pas mal
autant que madame hidalgo dont on parle
tant qu'ils me soutiennent et j'espère
qu'il y en aura plus
et donc je suis candidat bien évidemment
j'aurais les signatures et je les ai
déjà quasiment et nous
vivons nous y allons juste pour préciser
parce qu'on n'est pas sur le même
registre une partie de la droite a
appelé à faire barrage à marine le pen
vous vous étiez parti pour être le
premier ministre marine le pen vers 3
françois fillon ils ne sont jamais
partis n'ont jamais non pour jan 10
emmanuel macron monsieur philippe était
l air est devenu premier ministre vous
le referiez vous le referiez si la came
la question n'est pas là on est en 2021
france comptait encore avec marine le
pen aujourd'hui mes patries la continue
de vous tendre la main marine mai à
l'étang de la main ça veut dire quoi
si ça veut dire produire 2017
c'est à dire retrouver un duel que
refuse 80% des français 70 derniers
sondages pour aboutir à la réélection
des manuels macron ça c'est pas pour moi
parce que et c'est pour ça que je suis
candidat parce que j'estime que les
français ne veulent pas voir à nouveau
ce duel réducteur et je remarque qu
emmanuel macron assez intelligemment ne
faut pas le faut au moins lui
reconnaître ça il a détruit le pays mais
il est quelqu'un d'intelligent et bien
il a choisi son adversaire parce qu'il
veut être réélu c'est normal mais moi je
suis pas obligé de vouloir absolument
faire réélire emmanuel macron et
j'estime que marine le pen est le
meilleur adversaire pour emmanuel macron
moi je pense qu'il faut voir avec
emmanuel mac je pense qu'il faut battre
emmanuel macron je pense que les
français méritent un autre duel
je ne suis pas sûr que ni emmanuel
macron ni marine le pen ne serons au
second tour si nous sommes capables
d'offrir aux français une autre voie cet
autre voie je la construis je la prépare
et je l'offrirai aux français pour
qu'ils aient le choix
mais après le libre français de voter
s'ils le sont au second tour emmanuel
mercredi un appel là qu'est ce que vous
voulez bien on verra en attendant je
suis certain mais est-ce que je suis
heureux discuterait avec la chaîne est
ce que vous aurez la même démarche eco
je n'en sais absolument rien parce que
ce que dont je suis certain c'est que
les français ne veulent pas de ce duel
et je ferai tout pour dire aux français
il ya une autre voie possible
il y a on peut regretter notre pays qui
est un pays qu'à plein d'atouts et qui
détruit par la simplification
le degré zéro du débat politique et
j'espère l'espoir fait toujours vivre
j'espère être capable de proposer aux
français de vrais choix pour traiter les
racines des problèmes face furet
services publics deuxième tueur oui tout
à fait mais ça sera peut-être pas macron
qui vous dit que ça serait manuel mâcon
qui vous dit même qu'il pourra se
représenter
je n'en suis pas vous en doutez oui
quand on voit l'état du pays aujourd'hui
sa responsabilité immense dans la
destruction du pays
je suis pas du tout sûr qu emmanuel
mâcon sera candidat et merci beaucoup
merci nicolas dupont aignan d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin vers la une du
dauphiné
fabrice ce qui vous attend après pâques
de votre journal merci messieurs
[Musique]